welcome everybody to yet another
incredible AI advancement shared with us
by Google research prompt to prompt
image editing with cross attention
control put simply its diffusion model
image editing via natural language or
text historically when you generate
images with something like stable
diffusion you will probably take some
prompt and generate hundreds of examples
until you find one that you like and
even then there might be some small
things that you wish you could change or
maybe take from one image and put it in
the other one but unfortunately any
slight change in prompt or seed will
likely result in a vastly different
image and this is because diffusion
models essentially generate images from
a lead by a text prompt but starting
from random noise and this is why and
how you can generate hundreds of images
from the exact same text prompt by just
merely changing the random seed as well
as why if you generate from the same
prompt same settings and same seed you
will get the same exact results
so if you just want to make a small
change there have been some basic
Solutions other than I suppose uh image
Chopper something like that uh image
besides Photoshop there have been some
solutions like in painting where you can
mask a portion of the image and then
refill it and you can even guide the
refilling to a very large extent but you
can very often clearly see like where
the in painting had occurred and it can
still be often quite hard to control the
exact output now prompt to prompt not
only gives you an incredible image
editing capability but this research
also gives us a lot of insight into just
how much these diffusion models actually
understand the imagery that they create
and as far as I can tell for image
editing it seems like prompted prompt
does a way better job than someone in
Photoshop would do and definitely in
painting so prompt to prompt is open
source research and a good place to
start is the paper itself along with the
GitHub page that they have shared where
you can find a notebook that shows
examples of prompt to prompt being
applied to stable diffusion and you can
play with it yourself all the examples
that I'm showing here and I'm going to
show here are just kind me editing that
notebook so if you want to play with it
that is the place to do it building on
that notebook and trying my own examples
here are some of what I found so let's
start with just a object replacement
taking the following prompt cyberpunk
man on a motorcycle and a seed of 7607
we get the following image from here we
can inspect the cross attention maps and
see which areas of the image wait the
most in relation to specific tokens or
words I find this alone actually very
interesting I'm sure it's been done
somewhere but I have not seen this being
applied to diffusion models and just
this alone is actually kind of cool to
kind of check out and see what was the
model kind of thinking in terms of what
tokens match what in the image image
noting here for example that like
cyberpunk kind of is in relation to the
entire image which makes sense it's
responsible for the overall look and
feel of the image man is the person or
figure on the motorcycle and on and a
appear to mostly be like the head and
motorcycle seems to indeed be mainly the
motorcycle but also largely
related to the rider on top of it as
well which again illustrates that the
model has at least figured out that this
specific motorcycle depiction includes
the rider on it based on that text
prompt and the attention and all that it
understands it's not just a motorcycle
it's a rider on that motorcycle which
again is is really cool it understands
the intention of the text and also kind
of understands what it has created for
us now what happens if we want to change
the prompt slightly making the output a
cyberpunk woman on a motorcycle instead
without prompt to prompt this is what we
get and curiously enough the background
is surprisingly similar this won't
always be the case but she's definitely
not even on a motorcycle and the
background being similar in this case is
most likely just because of the prompt
itself so the concept of cyberpunk X on
y would likely have the same background
no matter what and since it was from the
same random seed and all that it kind of
makes sense to me that the background is
the same but depending on the type of
prompt and what you're doing or what
you're trying to create in that image
that won't necessarily always be the
case but obviously take that take that
into cons into consideration so even
though the backgrounds are pretty
similar it's definitely a different
image so now let's try this with prompt
to prompt and here we can see that this
time we've actually got the exact same
motorcycle or very very close the same
pose obviously the same background but
rather than a man we have a woman on the
motorcycle notably too even though the
jacket has changed to be a more feminine
I guess jacket the kind of halfway open
jacket style remains and the helmet is
pretty similar and a lot of the other
details are just very similar which is
just cool to see it's just kind of nerdy
thing I guess but it's cool but also
it's cool because it worked we were able
to just simply swap out man for a woman
and edit with natural language and it
just simply worked and that is just so
cool to me so not all single word
switches need to be so basic so since
cyberpunk for example is the overall
look and feel for that entire image as
we've seen from that cross attention
Maps uh what might happen if we change
the token for cyberpunk so for example
what if we changed cyberpunk to
SteamPunk what we get here is a very
different background clothing style
though again still note that kind of
half open jacket situation again and the
Motorcycle is very similar but it's more
steampunky looking and the placement of
the motorcycle the Rider and the overall
kind of the structure of the image is
all very similar if not this same I
would say
and again it's just so cool to me that
this works I just I I can't get over
this because without that prompt and
without using prompt to prompt here we
would the result would be a vastly
different image so for example we can
try another stylistic word change from
cyberpunk to Baroque and again this time
we have an even more similar image with
just a stylistic change again I just I
really enjoy how much the style has
changed but the overall image the
structure the placement of things
it's all basically the same we still
have buildings in the background that
are structurally similar to he's on like
a similar-ish type of street anyway it's
just this is cool so so another
stylistic change that we could make
could be something like cartoon so
here's an example of a cartoonify so to
speak
and
I I know I keep saying it but I just
think it's so cool how these changes can
be done so easily with prompt to prompt
the possibilities for the future of not
just image creation but also like image
editing are staggering especially for
someone like me who is not good at photo
editing like the ability to do this and
then apply little tweaks and edits
um it's it's just massive okay let's try
another concept we've shown that we can
change a word which would effectively
change something like the style or an
object in that image now let's actually
add more detail to The Prompt so for
example what if we add in the snow to
the end so in this case it now looks
like it's actually snowing in the
picture revisiting our previous image
that we've seen before too it does a
really good job of this as well again
we're going from no snow to yep it's
actively snowing in this photo but
everything else is stays the same I also
think it's particularly interesting
maybe a few of you noticed the
difference here but I find it very
interesting how this is the first time
that the jacket has been like fully
zipped up or closed instead of that like
half open all the way up to this point
so this could just be by chance or it's
the model actually recognizes or just
knows from seeing so many photos that
where you have things that indicate that
it's cold people are more often than not
just like bundled up so it seems to
suggest more research would be required
there but my guess is that yes in most
cases where you have snow let's say or
associations with things that would be
cold the people in that image it would
look weird if someone was in their
bathing suit now we probably couldn't
make an edit and make that person in
their bathing suit if we want it but but
um I think just if you let the model
decide it will zip up that jacket which
again I think is just so cool to see so
we can add more to prompts we can change
words but also we can modify the
weighting of particular tokens so for
example let's increase the weighting for
cyberpunk
again that's that's pretty cool and
interesting like you can kind of Max it
out a little more the overall potential
here is honestly pretty staggering if if
you couldn't already just prompt your
way to the Perfect Image you can find
one that's almost perfect and edit it
through natural language Beyond this
let's not forget the last video's
research also from Google where we
converted 2D imagery from diffusion
models to actual 3D objects that you
could import into your 3D programs games
whatever
beyond that multiple groups of
researchers are working very hard on
text video as well also referenced in
that previous video so once again we
find ourselves not too many steps away
from crazy realities where we can fine
tune and tweak text to 3D environments
that are again all just generated by a
neural network and they don't have to be
text to 3D it could even just be plain
user input to continued 3D environments
in the last video where I showed text to
3D objects one comment that I got a few
times on that video was how these
objects don't have real properties to
them so they don't have like if you you
had a pineapple you cracked open that
pineapple there would be nothing inside
that pineapple for example so thus
they're not useful for you know VR games
environments and stuff like that the
thing is the way that something like
text to video works is it understands
how objects should interact with each
other otherwise the videos would not
look realistic
so this again is a major shift that I
think is coming for like 3D VR Gaming
Etc we simply won't be assigning rules
to objects like we have always done
which is always faulty
um an AI will come up with and control
those properties like physics and what's
inside if you happen to crack open that
pineapple what would be Insider just the
very capability that you could crack
open that pineapple that would be
controlled by an AI the neural network
that is generating the rest of that
video feed now I know some of you are
sitting back thinking that's absurd
science fiction and or that's 50 years
away but it is not in fact we've
actually done something very similar to
that on this channel based on Nvidia
research with Gans where we taught in AI
not how to play Grand Theft Auto 5
although we've done that too but instead
to actually be the Grand Theft Auto 5
for us as players and humans to play
Within and again the output was nothing
more than an image generated from the
model which simply reacted based on
keyboard presses and previous frames and
this worked
even in this example physics worked they
happened the car had Shadows that worked
walls were solid right we could drive on
the road in turn the car's suspension
leaned when we turned and more these
were not things that we coded or
attributes that we added they were
simply merely visual choices that the
model made in response to the keyboard
presses that we made so we didn't say
you can't go through this wall it was
just the neural network understood you
can't go through that wall therefore
we're going to make it look like you
just the car stopped and hit a wall dare
I say that the future of these 3D
environments that you can interact with
where the environment and all the rules
and everything within it are handled by
a neural network that future is
right now
the only difference between what we did
with Gan Theft Auto and what I'm
describing here is that you could just
start off with a simple text prompt or
something like that and all those things
it doesn't have to necessarily be a game
that it watched you play it could just
be real life that's a big change but
again the technology to do it and the
functionality and the capability of a
neural network to basically be mapping
not just the visuals but also
essentially the visuals but as they
relate to physics and all these other
things
that's not Science Fiction it's right
now it's it's already happened that was
years ago
with that I just cannot wait to see what
like the next one to three years has in
store for us it's been a lot of fun and
challenging just to Simply keep up with
the latest advancements and there's so
many things that I haven't even looked
at yet that I still need to catch up on
um it's just what a crazy time to be in
in this space and again I think like
many things like the release of Bloom
like you know I think I think the
general public seems to be pretty aware
of what's going on with like diffusion
models but all the other ancillary stuff
I think people have no idea and even the
general public it seems like most people
are worried about other things besides
the capability like people think the
main thing about diffusion models is
going to be the oh that you can just all
you can do is just generate fun imagery
and then it's it gets after a week or
two you get bored of it and you move on
I think people are completely missing
what craziness is happening and
unfolding right now and what it's going
to mean for the future so anyway as
always links to everything are in the
description including the prompt to
prompt paper and the associated GitHub
as well as text to 3D with dream Fusion
that we talked about a couple weeks ago
Grand Theft Auto and finally a link to
the neural networks from scratch book
which teaches you everything you need to
know for creating training all of that
and how to use your neural networks from
scratch and I don't mean from scratch
with pytorch like the other guys I mean
really from scratch in Python so check
out
nnfs.io if that sounds interesting to
you and to learn more otherwise I will
see you all in another video